I swear to God
[Music]
Just a minute, but
I seek refuge in God from the accursed Satan. In
the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
If this Qur’an were on a mountain, it would see its sublime majesty, I would see
it humbled and torn apart
from the fear of God.
[Music]
And these are proverbs that We present to the people so that they may think.
He is
God. He is God. There is
no god but He, the Knower of the Unseen.  And the testimony is He, the Most
Gracious, the Most Merciful
[Music]
Oh, by God,
besides Whom there is no god, the King, the Holy, the Peace, the Believer, the Dominant, the Mighty, the Mighty, the
Arrogant. Glory be to God
above what they associate with Him. He is God, the Creator, the Creator, the Creator. He has the most
beautiful names. He
glorifies them in the heavens and the earth, and He is the Mighty, the
Teller
[Music]
Mosque [Music]
music]